welcome to numpy my name is Richard
Kirchner with the simply learned team
sww simply learn comm get certified get
ahead what's in it for you well today
we're going to do part one of numpy in a
two-part series now we're gonna go over
what is numpy installing an importing
numpy number array numpy array vs Python
list basics of numpy finding size and
shape of any array range and arrange
functions numpy string functions and
then a part two we'll move on to cover
axes array manipulation and much more
so let's start with what is num be num
be is the core library for scientific
and numerical computing in python it
provides high performance
multi-dimensional array object and tools
for working with arrays and I'll go a
step further and say there are so many
other modules in Python built on numpy
so the fundamentals of numpy are so
important to latch on to for the Python
since you can understand the other
modules and what they're doing num
beasts main object is a
multi-dimensional array it's a table of
elements usually numbers all of the same
type indexed by a tuple of position
integers in num be dimensions are called
axes take a one-dimensional array or we
have remember dimensions are also called
axes you can say this is the first axis
0 1 2 3 4 5 and you can see down here it
has a shape of 6 why cuz there's six
different elements in it in the one
dimension array and they do usually
denote that a 6 comma with an empty note
on there and then we have a two
dimensional array where you can see 0 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 and in here we have two axes
or two dimensions and the shape is 2 4
so if you were looking at this as a
matrix or in other mathematical
functions you can use all kinds of
importance on shape we're not going to
cover shape today but we will cover that
in part 2 did you know that num peas
array class is called in D array for
numpy data array now we're going to take
a detour here because we're working in
Python and two of my favorite tools in
Python is the Jupiter
no book and then I like to use that
sitting on top of anaconda and if you
flip over to Jupiter org that's jup y te
r dot org you can go in here you can
install it off of here if you don't want
to use the Anaconda notebook but this is
the Jupiter setup the documentation on
the Jupiter Jupiter opens up in your web
browser that's what makes it so nice is
it's portable the files are saved on
your computer they do run an eye Python
or ironpython
and you can create all kinds of
different environments in there which
I'll show you in just a minute I myself
like to use anaconda that's WWE anaconda
comm if you install anaconda it will
install the Jupiter notebook with the
anaconda separate and you can install
Jupiter notebook and he'll run
completely separate from anacondas
Jupiter notebook and you can see here
I've now opened up my anaconda navigator
what I like about the navigator and this
is a fresh install and a new computer
which is always nice I can launch my
Jupiter notebook from in here I can
bring other tools so the anaconda does a
lot more and under environments I only
have the one environment and I can open
up the terminal specific to this
environment this one happens to have
Python 3 7 in it the most current
version as of this tutorial and the open
of terminal if you're gonna do your pip
installs and stuff like that for
different modules you can also create
different environments in here so maybe
you need a Python 3 6 Python 3 5 you can
see we're having a nice framework like
anaconda really helps so you don't have
to chat track that on your own in the
Jupiter notebook and your different
Jupiter notebook setups we'll go ahead
and launch this Jupiter notebook and
then I've set my browser window for a
deep fault of chrome so it's gonna open
up in chrome and you can see here this
opens up a folder on my computer we have
a couple different options on here
remember I set the environment up as
Python 3.7 you would install any
additional modules and aren't already
installed in your Python on this and to
keeps them separate so you do have two
for each environment install the
separate module so they match the
environment on there and in here we have
a couple things we can look up what's
running do you have your different
clusters again this is I just installed
this on a new machine so I just have the
one a couple things in here that were
run on here recently and when we go on
here is we then have
the upper right new and from the
pulldown menu you'll see Python 3 and
this will open up a new window and now
we're in Jupiter Python so this is a
Python window and we'll just do a print
and this of course is a so hello world
and we'll run that and prints out hello
world in the command line there's a
couple special things you have to know
we're not going to do today which is on
graphics if you've never seen this one
of the things you can do is you can also
do a equals hello world and if you just
put the a in there now if you do a bunch
of these where you have a equals hello
world B equals goodbye world and you put
a be a then return B you'll only run the
last one but you can see here if you put
the variable down here it will show you
what's in that variable and that has to
do with the Jupiter notebook in line
coding so that's not basic Python this
just super notebook shorthand which
you'll see in a little bit so back to
our numpy numpy array versus Python list
Python this being the basic list in your
Python why should we use numpy array
when we have Python list
well first it's fast the numpy array has
been optimized over years and years but
multiple programmers and it's usually
very quick compared to the basic Python
list set up it's convenient so it has a
lot of functionality in there there's
not in the basic Python list and it also
uses less memory so it's optimized both
for speed and memory use and let's go
ahead and jump in to our Jupiter
notebook since we're coding best way to
learn coding is to code just like the
best we're going to learn how to write
is right and the best way to learn how
to cook is cook so let's do some coding
here today and just like any modules we
have to import numpy we almost always
import it as in p that is such a
standard so you'll see that very
commonly we can just run that and now we
have access to our numpy module inside
our Python and then the most common
thing of course is to go ahead and
create a number array and in here we can
send it a regular list and so we'll go
ahead and send this a regular array
let's go 1 2 3 to make it simple and
then I'm just going to type in a and
we'll run this
so you can see down here the output is
an array of 1 2 3 and we could also do
print just a reminder that this is an
inline command so that wouldn't work if
you're using a different editor you can
see this an array 1 2 3 but we'll go and
leave it as a kind of a nice features
you can see what you're doing really
quick and the jupiter notebook and just
like all your other standard arrays i
can go a of 0 which is going to be a
value of 1 of course we do a of 1 you go
all the way through this if one has a
value of 2 in it so whether you're using
the numpy array or the basic Python list
that's gonna be the same that should all
look pretty familiar and be pretty
straightforward remember the first value
is always 0 and when we sit on there so
let's take a look why we're using numpy
because we went over the slide a little
bit let's just take a look and see what
that actually looks like and what we
want to look at is the fact that it's
fast convenient and uses less memory so
let's take a glance at that in code and
see what that actually looks like when
we're writing it in Python and what the
differences are and to do this I'm gonna
go ahead and import a couple other
modules we're going to import the time
module so we can time it and we're going
to import the system module so that we
can take a look at how much memory it
uses and we'll go and just run those so
those are imported so we'll do B equals
range of 1 got 1000 fine and so that's
going to create a list of 1000 0 to 999
member starts at 0 and it stops right at
the 1000 without actually going to the
1000 and let's go ahead and print we
want system dot get size of and we'll
pick any integer because we have you
know zero to a thousand we'll just throw
one in there 5 it doesn't matter it's
good
whatever integer we put in there's gonna
generate the same value in the size of
how how much memory it stores an integer
in and then we want to have the link of
the beat that's how many integers are in
there and if we go ahead and execute
this and run this in a line we'll see
oops I did that wrong comma if we
multiply them together
we'll see it generates 28,000 so that's
the size we're looking at is 28,000 I
mean that's bytes that sounds about
right so let's go ahead and create this
in numpy and we'll go as C equals NP and
this is a range so that's the number
command to do the same thing that we
were just doing in a list and we'll also
use the same value on there the 1000
once we've created the C value of C for
in P dot a arrange let's go ahead and
print and we can do that by doing C dot
size times C dot item size well that's
very similar we did before we did get
the size of so the C size is the size of
the array and each item size just
reversed so it's the size of an integer
five item size it's gonna be the
integers and C size let's just take a
look and see what that generates and Wow
okay we got 4000 versus 28,000 that's a
significant difference in memory how
much memory we're using with the array
and then let's go ahead and take a look
at speed let's do let's do sighs we
trade this with lower values and it
would happen so fast that the NPR a kept
coming up with zero
because it just rounded it off so size
and let's create an l1 Bulls range of
size
I'll do an l2 I'll just set up to the
same thing it's also range of size on
and then we can do on a1 equals in P dot
a range size and then let's do on a2
equals in P dot a range will keep it the
same size
and what we're going to do is we're
going to take these two different arrays
we're gonna perform some basic functions
on them but let's go ahead access load
these up now we'll go ahead and run this
so those are all set in memory
so for the typo here
quickly fix that there we go so these
are now all loaded in here and let's do
a start
equals
time time so it's just going to look at
my clock time and see what time it is
and it will do result equals and let's
do oh let's say we got an array and
we're gonna say let's do some addition
here X plus y for X comma Y and we'll
zip it up here two different arrays so
here's our two different arrays we're
going to multiply each of the individual
things on here l1 l2
there we go so that should add up each
values for l1 plus l2 each value in each
array then we want to go ahead and print
and let's say python list took and they
will do
time dot we'll just subtract the start
out of there so time whoops I missed up
on some of the quotation marks on there
okay there we go time minus the start
and we'll convert that to second so you
owe us in milliseconds sir times 1000
and let's hit the run bond there it's
kind of fun because you also get a view
while we're doing this of some ways to
manipulate the script and as you can see
also my bed typing there we go okay so
we'll go ahead and run this and we can
see here that the Python list took 34
actually I have to go back and look at
the conversion on there but you can see
it takes roughly 0.34 of a second and we
go ahead and print the result in here
too let's do that I'll run that just so
you can see what the what kind of data
we're looking at
and we have the zero two four six eight
so it's just adding them together it
looks pretty straightforward on there
and if we scroll down to the bottom of
the answer again we see Python list took
46 a little different time on there
depending on what core because I have
this is on an eight core computer so
just depends on what cores running on
what else is pulling on the computer at
the time and let's go back up here and
do our start time fit that into here and
this time we're gonna do a result equals
and this is really cool notice how
elegant this is is so straightforward
this is a lot of reason people started
using numpy is because I can add the two
arrays together by simply going a 1 plus
a 2 makes a lot of sense both looking at
it and it's just very convenient
remember that slag we're looking at fast
convenient and less memory so look how
convenient that is really easy to read
real easy to see and I don't know if we
don't need to print the result again so
let's just go ahead and print the time
on here and we'll borrow this from the
top part because I really am a lazy type
and this isn't the Python list this is
the numpy list or number array and let's
go ahead and see how that comes out and
we get 2.99 so let's take these two
numbers 46 versus 2.99 so we'll just
round this up to 3 that's a huge
difference that's that's like more than
10 times faster that's like 15 times
roughly at a quick glance I'd have to go
do the math to look at it it's gonna
vary a little bit depending on what's
running in the background the computer
obviously so we've looked at this and if
we go back here we found out it's much
faster yes there's different gonna be
different speeds depending on what
you're doing with the array very
convenient easy to read and it uses less
memory so that's the core of the numpy
that's why a lot of people base so many
other modules on numpy and why it's so
widely used so we did glanced at a
couple operations when we're looking at
speed and size let's dive into a little
bit more into the basic operations these
are always nice to see means certainly
you want to go get a cheat sheet if
using it for the first time
sup Google is your friend we did this
with the most basic numpy array or NP
dot array and will go ahead and create
an array let's do pairs 1 comma 2 and
then let's do a 3 comma 4 if we're gonna
do that let's do 5 comma 6
there we go and if we go ahead and take
this and run this I can go ahead and do
our a down here so it's in line it'll
print that out you can see makes a nice
array for us so we have a and if you
look at that we have three different
objects each with two values in them and
hopefully you're starting to think well
how many dimensions or indexes is that
and you'll see three by two so let's go
ahead and take a look and let's go how
about a dot in dimensions
speaking of which we'll run that and we
have two dimensions for each object and
then we can do the item size so a dot we
saw this earlier we looked up how many
items it was up here where we wanted to
multiply item size times the actual size
of the object so the memory is being
used versus the item size and we should
see for their memories can press down
that's always a good thing and then the
shape
the shape is so important when you're
working with data science and you're
moving it from one format to another so
we have our shape we just talked about
that we have three by two three rows by
two objects in each one generally I
don't look too much at the size but the
dimensions I'm always looking up this is
nice you can automate it so you may be
converting something you might need to
know how many dimensions are going into
the next machine learning package so
that you can automatically just have it
send that information over so we looked
at a shape let's go and create a
slightly different array in P dot array
let's go ahead just do as our original
setup here
and one of the features we can do which
is really important as we can do D type
equals in this case let's do NP float64
and so what we've done is reverting all
of these into a float when we've type an
A and now instead of having 1 2 3 4 5 6
you see they're all float values 1.0 and
there's no actual 0 and they're just
sort of one dot or the one period 2 3 .
for period 5 period 6 period and this
again
data science I don't know how many times
they've had to convert something from an
integer to a float so that's gonna work
correctly in the model I'm using so very
common features to be aware of and to be
able to get around and use I'll also do
let's just curiosity item size we'll go
ahead and run that and we see that it
doubled in size so it's not a huge
increase well doubling is always a big
increase in computers but it's not a
huge increase compared to what it would
be if you're running this in the Python
list format and then we did the shape
earlier without having it set to the
float 64 let's go ahead and do a shape
with it set to 64 and it should be the
same three comma two so it all matches
so we've gone through and remember if
you really if this is all brand new to
you according to the Cambridge study at
the cam Bridge University if you're
learning a brand new word in a foreign
language the average person has to
repeated 160 three times before it's
memorized so a lot of this you build off
of it so hopefully you don't have to
repeat it 163 times but we did manage to
repeat it at least twice here if not a
little bit more and let's go ahead and
take this we're gonna go look at one
more set up on here and let me just take
this last statement here and converting
our properties of our data and instead
of float64 let's do complex let's just
see what that looks like and let's go
ahead and print that out and run it
and so we now have a complex data setup
and you'll see it's denoted by the 1 dot
plus 0 J and if we flip over here and do
a basic search for numpy datatypes
better to go to the original webpage but
pull up a bunch of these you can see
there's a whole list of different numpy
datatypes shorthand complex we have
complex complex 64 complex 128 complex
number represented by 2 64 bit floats
real and imaginary components one option
on their float with 16 float 32 floats
or ahead for float64 most commonly used
and of course all the different ones
that you can possibly put into your
numpy array so we covered basic addition
up there we're comparing how fast it
runs with some very basic components how
to set up a numpy array how many
dimensions it has item size data type
item again we went to item size and
there's also the shape probably one of
the more used I used a shape all the
time very commonly used
and then down here you can see where we
actually created a numpy complex data
type so let's look at some other
features in numpy one of them is you
could do numpy dot zeroes and we're
gonna do 3 comma 4
there we go and we'll go ahead and run
this and you can see if I do in p0s I
created numpy array of zeros this is
really important I was building my own
neural network and I needed to create an
array where I initialize the weights and
I won them all to be the same weight in
this case I wanted him to start off as
zero for the particular project I was
working on and there's other options
that you can do num peatones
and we'll do the same thing 3 comma 4
I'll run that and you can see I've
created a an array of numpy ones in this
case it comes out as a float array and
then this is an interesting that note
because we have let's go back to our
Python and do L range 5 and we'll print
the L so those are lists and if I run
that it doesn't create the range until
after the fact until you actually
execute it that's an upgrade in Python
Python true 7 actually created the array
0 1 2 3 4 this one actually creates the
script and then once it's used it then
actually generates the array and if we
do that in number a range remember that
from before and if we do a numpy a range
5 and let's do L equals R we can just
leave it as numpy that's wrong there we
go
just run
you can see there we actually get an
array 0 1 2 3 4 4 the value of the
number your age a range 5 it generates
the actual array and for part 1 we're
going to do just one more section on
basic set up and we're going to
concatenation to a concatenation example
there we go we're gonna do strings let's
take a look at strings what's going on
with there and let's do
oh let's see print let's do an NP
character something new here and we're
going to add and then here's our
brackets for what we're gonna add oh
let's say let's do hello comma hi and in
the brackets on there let's create
another one and this one's going to be e
that's ABC we'll do XYZ so we're just
creating something randomly making some
up on here and then we'll go ahead and
just print this if we run that and come
down here and of course make sure all
your brackets are open and closed
correctly content you can see in here
when we concatenate the example in numpy
it takes the two different arrays that
we set up in there and it combined the
hello with the ABC and the hi with XYZ
and if we can also do something like
print oh let's do NP character dot
multiply so there's a lot of different
functions in here again you can look
these up it's probably good to look them
all up and see what they are but it's
good also there's sea lemon actually
let's do hello space comma 3 and we'll
run this one and run that without the
error you'll see does hello hello hello
so we multiplied it by 3 and we can also
let's just take this whole thing here
instead of retyping it and we can do
character center so instead of multiply
this to Center
and over here keeper hello going take
the space out of there and let's do the
center at 20 and fill character equals
we'll fill it with dashes so if we run
this
you can see it prints out the hello with
dashes on each side and we keep going
along with that we can also addition to
doing the fill function we can play with
capitalize we can title we can do
lowercase we can do uppercase we can
split split line strip join these are
all the most common ones and let's go
ahead and just look at those and see
what those look like each one of them
here we're going to do the hello world
all-time favorite of mine I was like say
hello universe and you can see here we
did a capital H with the world but so we
want to capitalize so capitalize is the
first one in the array so we get hello
world on there and we can also take this
and instead of capitalizing another
feature in here is title and this just
changed this to how are we doing how are
you doing that I wanted to do you let's
run that and you can see here because we
created it as a title that capitalizes
the first letter in each word and in
this one we're going to do character
lower two different examples here we
have an array we have hello world all
capitalized and we have just hello and
you can see that one is an array and one
is just a string if we run that you get
a array with hello world lowercase and
hello lowercase and if we're going to do
it that way we can also do it the apps
away there's also ever
and let's paste those in there and you
can see here we have character upper
opposite there Python data and that will
do Python is easy hopefully you're
starting to get the picture that most of
the Python and the scripting is very
simple it's when you put the bigger
picture together and starts building
these puzzles and somebody asks you hey
I need the first letter capitalised
unless it's the title and then we have
you start realizing that this can get
really complicated so num beats it
simple and we like that and so in this
case we did Python data it's all
uppercase Python is easy like shouting
in your messenger Python is easy and
then if you're ever a processing text
and tokenizing it a lot of times the
first thing you do is we just split the
text and we're just gonna run this in P
character dot split are you coming to
the party if we do that returns an array
of each of the individual words are you
coming to the party splitting it by the
spaces and then if you're gonna split it
by spaces we also need to know how to
split it by lines and just like we have
the basic split command we also have
split lines hello and you'll see here
the scoop in for our new line and when
we run that if you're following the
split part with the words you should see
hello how are you doing the two
different lines are now split apart and
let's just review three more before we
wrap this up commonly used string
variable manipulations we have strip and
in this case we have Nina admin Anita
and we're gonna strip a off of there
let's see what that looks like and then
you end up with ninda min Nate it
basically takes up all leading and
trailing letters in this case we're
looking for a more common would be a
space in there but it might also be
punctuation or anything like that that
you need to remove from your letters and
words and if we're gonna strip and clean
data we also need to be able to reformat
it or join it together so you see here
we have a character join will go and run
this
and it has on the first one it splitsies
the letters up by the colon and the
second one by the dash and you can see
how this is really useful if you're
processing in this case a date we have
day month year year month date very
common things do you have to always
switch around and manipulate depending
on what they're going into and what
you're working with and finally let's
look at one last character string we're
gonna do replace for doing
misinformation this is good pulling news
articles replacing is and what in this
case we're just doing here's a good
dancer and we're gonna replace is with
was and you can see here he was a good
dancer hopefully that's not because he
had a bad fall he just was from like you
know 1920s and has gotten old so there
we go we've covered a lot of the basics
in numpy as far as creating an array
very important stuff here when you're
feeding it in how do we know the shape
of it the size of it what happens we
convert it from a regular integer into a
float value as far as how much space it
takes we saw that that doubled it item
size you have your in dimensions and
probably the most used is shape we'll
cover more on shape in part two so make
sure you join us on part tube there's a
lot of important things on shaping in
there and setting them up we also saw
that you can create a zeros based array
you can create one with ones if we do a
range you can see how it is a lot easier
to use to create its own range or a
range as it is numpy he saw easy it was
to add two arrays we saw that earlier
just plus sign then we got into doing
strings and working with strings and how
to concatenate so if you have two
different arrays of strings you can
bring them together we also saw how you
can fill so you can add a nice headline
dash dash dash we saw about capitalize
the first letter we saw about turning it
into a title so all the first letters
are capitalized and doing lowercase on
all the letters upper for all the
letters just lower an upper nice
abbreviation we also covered how to
split the character set how to strip it
so if you want to strip all the A's out
from leading a A's and ending A's or
spaces you can do that very easily also
how to join the data sets so here's a
character join option for your strings
and finally we did the character replace
we covered a lot in part one Python
numpy part two is gonna come up please
make sure you join us for that as we
dive deeper into a lot of the different
functionality thank you for joining us
today
for more information visit
www.cannainsider.com/careers
to nerd up and get certified click here